because i'm asian and yeah i give a
[ __ ] food
yeah baby how'd you get that black eye
oh my god dude wait what i have a black
eye right here
you can't really see it on oh yeah the
bottom left yeah you got a fight
no i was um beat the [ __ ] out of him no
saturday night so
we had a big ordeal saturday night
number one
it wasn't an ordeal no but i had a lot
of pressure
number one so the the people that i'm on
the sitcom with
they wanted they wanted to come see me
perform
okay so we had dinner at lindsay price's
husband's restaurant oh
gwen gwen curtis curtis
stone the guy's amazing yeah so lindsay
meets us there with oliver hudson
and diane farr
and curtis is there he's he's
crazy our waiter that's ridiculous and
curtis stone is
just going this is what i'm going to do
for you guys you know what i mean this
and that australian
yeah and then he we just had the best
meal you could possibly have
customized amazing amazing it was off
the menu too he was just like any food
restrictions or like nope
he was like okay i'll just cook for you
yeah here's what wagyo beef steak
and it was like a plate of it
lamb shampoo just lame shank just like
just the best food you could ever have
that's crazy and it you had like a
pre-dessert before a real dessert
yeah to cleanse your palate yeah
it was some like citrusy like just yeah
amazing amazing [ __ ]
and then so she takes off because she
wants to go to this halloween party that
michael rose obama's doing
oh he said if we flake he'll never speak
to us again whatever he will because he
said that to me before and that's like
nine times too nice though he'll never
and he'll always he always accepts
people
he calls you christian bale i am oh he
calls him bobby leave
oh really bobby leave i love honey
that's good spread that around shout out
rosenbaum yeah
but anyway so dinner yeah so then they
come to my show
right and i'm back there and i'm so
excited to get up on stage
it's so dark back there and i run into a
speaker
and it hits my eye right here and then
my eye starts
vibrating you know i mean and i know
it's going to turn into a black eye
and also on top of it i started feeling
sick
it was just a and then and then i get up
there i
the show was okay i give them the tour
of the club
but then [ __ ] it's now midnight and
this [ __ ] is like
you're gonna i i put the yoko oh no
you'll
own an outfit in your car you gotta come
so i'm frantically putting the
owner away i was wearing i didn't
have uh time to buy the wig the whole
john lennon mustache thing so i was like
i'm just gonna
bring you know wear white stuff out of
my closet right
but it's not going to make sense if yoko
doesn't show up
the only thing i had going for me was
like the 70s glasses so i was like okay
no one's going to [ __ ] know that i'm
supposed to be john lennon my wife shows
up when you shut up you look like uh
tall yoko
so i get there um with jessica and jenna
and i call bobby and i was like where
are you he's like i'm at some random
parking lot trying to put this [ __ ] off
because he didn't want to let me down
yeah because i had like you know
i had a bad attitude earlier that night
i show up in this thing it's like a
[ __ ] dive bar
right oh it's not his house it's a bunch
of comedians i know a lot of people
there
i literally just walk through it i do a
circle around it i do a little quick
dance moves
documented and i just laughed oh you
didn't even stay
at all nah what's the point yeah he
doesn't drink i don't
drink you know i'm not single i'm in a
relationship
there's no point okay yeah
so i left and uh i know i'm deathly ill
it was a pretty okay night yeah that is
the
funniest costume i've ever seen in my
entire life you saw it i saw it
yeah i think you're funny because i live
with you i mean we laugh at little
things here and there but i was
on the floor for 20 minutes in tears
i was screaming i thought it was the he
just if you had to have seen him in
person it was 50 times better than the
picture
because the way he was moving too and
his ass crack was out yeah yeah
well that's how he do it he knows how to
work a room i know it'll work there's
how to work a halloween room yeah but he
did this whole like different stance
where he was kind of like this
delicate he was like moving kind of
different too
you seem very turned on i was yeah it
was it was fun
yeah but the sickness is like it's it's
[ __ ]
this is the worst kind is that because
of the party i don't know what happened
no
last week um jenna fischer was sick
and she said kept saying i'm sick and i
was always like
real close to her i'm saying it to my
face and then i'm not gonna get him to
get it and
it just